WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS SEEK
AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
THIS YEAR WE WILL DO
$5 MILLION IN SALES.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE ALREADY
AT A MILLION.
WOW.
IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA,
THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
I REALLY LIKE YOU.
YOU'VE DONE SOMETHING
REMARKABLE.
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
HE'S TOO RICH AND TOO NUTS.
A MOMENT OF SILENCE FOR THAT
MONEY THAT JUST DIED.
ABSOLUTELY.
I'M WITH YOU THIS TIME.
BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS MUST GET
THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
[ CRYING ] I'M ENGAGED,
AND MY FIANCéE LIVES IN JAPAN,
AND SHE CAN'T COME OUT HERE
UNLESS I MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
MAYBE YOU CAN GET AN EMOTIONAL
CONNECTION GOING WITH BARBARA,
WHO LOVES TO SPEND MONEY
WHEN SHE STARTS TO CRY.
Lori:
INSTEAD OF KICKSTARTER,
SOMETIMES THEY CALL ME
THE "CHICKSTARTER."
IF YOU DON'T SELL THROUGH,
YOU'RE DEAD.
YOU MAY SEAL YOUR COMMITMENT
WITH A KISS.
DO IT!
[ LAUGHS ]
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE BUSINESS
EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS A SHREWD
VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN WENT FROM
WAITING TABLES IN MANHATTAN
TO BUILDING THE CITY'S PREMIER
$2 BILLION REAL ESTATE EMPIRE.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED OVER
400 PRODUCTS, GROSSING OVER
A HALF A BILLION DOLLARS
IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN, RENOWNED
BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
♪♪♪
FIRST INTO THE TANK
IS A PRODUCT DESIGNED
TO INSPIRE YOUNG GIRLS
TO EXPAND THEIR HORIZONS.
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS ALICE BROOKS.
AND MY NAME IS BETTINA CHEN,
AND WE'RE FROM PALO ALTO,
CALIFORNIA.
OUR COMPANY IS ROOMINATE,
AND WE ARE SEEKING
$500,000 IN EXCHANGE
FOR 5% OF OUR COMPANY.
OUR MISSION IS TO EMPOWER
THE NEXT GENERATION OF FEMALE
ENGINEERS AND INNOVATORS.
SHARKS, WE'D LIKE YOU TO THINK
BACK TO YOUR CHILDHOODS.
DO YOU REMEMBER
YOUR FAVORITES TOYS?
AND DID ANY OF THOSE TOYS
INFLUENCE YOUR SUCCESS TODAY?
BARBARA, WHAT IF INSTEAD OF
MAKING A REAL ESTATE DEAL
IN A BOARD GAME, YOU WERE ABLE
TO BUILD YOUR OWN HIGH-RISE?
AND, LORI, INSTEAD OF DRAWING
AN IDEA WITH A CRAYON,
WHAT IF YOU WERE ABLE TO BUILD
A PROTOTYPE?
IMAGINE HOW YOUNG
YOU WOULD HAVE BEEN
WHEN YOU WERE ISSUED
YOUR FIRST PATENT.
INTRODUCING ROOMINATE,
TOYS TO INSPIRE THE NEXT
GENERATION OF INNOVATION.
ROOMINATE IS A NEW
AND REVOLUTIONARY
WIRED BUILDING SYSTEM
FOR GIRLS AGE 6 AND UP.
LET'S SHOW YOU HOW IT WORKS.
FIRST YOU START
BY BUILDING THE STRUCTURE,
WITH THREE STORIES, BALCONIES,
EVEN SPIRAL STAIRCASES.
AND THE BEST PART ABOUT
ROOMINATE IS
THE WORKING CIRCUIT.
WIRE UP EVERYTHING
FROM SPINNING WINDMILLS
TO MERRY-GO-ROUNDS,
EVEN ELEVATORS.
Robert and Lori: [ CHUCKLE ]
AND MAKE IT ALL LIGHT UP.
WE ALREADY HAVE A COMMUNITY
OF THOUSANDS OF GIRLS AND BOYS
WHO WE CALL ROOMINATORS.
OUR ROOMINATORS
MAKE AMAZING CREATIONS
THAT WE NEVER WOULD HAVE
DREAMED OF MAKING,
EVERYTHING FROM
THE GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE
TO A CAR WASH,
EVEN A ROCKET SHIP.
WE ALSO HAVE SOME
SPECIAL ROOMINATES
TO PASS OUT TO EACH OF YOU.
OUR ROOMINATORS HELPED US
CREATE SOME.
TERRIFIC.
SO FOR YOU, MARK,
OF COURSE WE MADE YOU
THE MAVERICKS COURT...
I LIKE THAT.
WITH A PRIVATE PLANE
TO GET YOU THERE.
WITH A PRIVATE PLANE.
OF COURSE.
Robert and Lori: WOW.
BARBARA, OUR ROOMINATORS THOUGHT
THAT A SWANKY MANHATTAN CONDO
WOULD BE PERFECT FOR YOU.
I HOPE THEY'RE CHEAPER THAN
I PAY FOR THEM THERE.
[ LAUGHS ]
AND, MR. WONDERFUL,
WE'VE ALL HEARD
YOUR ICE CREAM SHOP STORY.
AH.
SO WE -- OUR ROOMINATORS HELPED
US BUILD YOU AN ICE CREAM SHOP.
LET'S SEE, KEVIN.
WHAT DOES IT DO?
THIS IS THE ICE CREAM STORE
I GOT FIRED IN,
SO I'M GONNA SET THIS
ON FIRE NOW.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND THEN, LORI, OUR ROOMINATORS
HELPED US MAKE YOU A QVC SET.
AND ALL THESE CREATIONS
HAVE A CIRCUIT IN THERE,
SO IF YOU PRESS
THE RED BUTTON,
IT WILL ACTIVATE IT.
AND, ROBERT, WE KNOW YOU LOVE
RACING CARS.
I DO.
SO THEY HELPED US MAKE YOU
A RACETRACK.
THANK YOU!
CAN I SEE ONE OF THE PACKAGES
SO I CAN SEE
HOW IT'S PACKAGED?
OH, YES. OH, WAIT --
Lori: COOL.
Robert: DOES THE CAR GO AROUND?
YOU CAN PUSH IT AROUND.
[ LAUGHS ]
RR...
[ LAUGHTER ]
THANK YOU.
WHAT MAKES THIS DIFFERENT
FROM LEGOS?
Alice: THIS IS ALL ABOUT
OPEN-ENDED PLAY.
SO WE GIVE THEM INSPIRATION
AND WE GIVE THEM IDEAS,
BUT ULTIMATELY IT'S UP
TO THE KIDS
TO DECIDE WHAT THEY WANT
TO BUILD.
HOW DID YOU GUYS COME UP
WITH THIS?
WELL, I STUDIED
MECHANICAL ENGINEERING
AT M.I.T. AND STANFORD.
AND I STUDIED
ELECTRICAL ENGINEERING
AT CALTECH AND STANFORD.
SO WE GOT TO STANFORD,
THE TWO OF US,
AND WE BECAME FRIENDS
RIGHT AWAY, BECAUSE
WE WERE TWO OF THE ONLY WOMEN
THERE IN ENGINEERING.
AH.
AND THAT GOT US TALKING,
YOU KNOW.
WE REALIZED THAT OUR
COMMON THREAD WAS THAT
WE'D BOTH BEEN INSPIRED
BY THINGS
THAT WE PLAYED WITH
WHEN WE WERE YOUNGER.
Barbara: MM.
AND FOR ME, IT WAS
WHEN I WAS 8 YEARS OLD.
I ASKED MY DAD, "CAN SANTA CLAUS
BRING ME A BARBIE THIS YEAR?"
AND HE SAID "NO."
AND INSTEAD I GOT MY OWN SAW.
AH!
SO I BUILT DOLLS AND DOLLHOUSES
OUT OF WOOD AND NAILS.
AND I JUST --
THAT JUST STARTED MY LOVE
OF ENGINEERING RIGHT THERE.
DID YOU HAVE A NATURAL
INTEREST TO BUILD THINGS,
OR DID YOUR DAD
PUSH YOU THAT WAY?
I THINK THAT ALL KIDS ARE OPEN
TO ALL DIFFERENT SORTS
OF THINGS.
THE PROBLEM RIGHT NOW
FOR GIRLS
IS THAT WE'RE NOT EXPOSING
THEM TO MORE OPTIONS.
SO WE'RE MISSING OUT ON HALF
OF THE POTENTIAL
PRODUCT DESIGNERS,
COMPUTER PROGRAMMERS RIGHT NOW.
HMM.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF US
THAT WE CAN GET GIRLS
DOING THESE SORTS OF THINGS.
AND WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
WE HAVE $1.7 MILLION
IN SALES TO DATE.
AMAZING.
THIS -- THIS CALENDAR YEAR?
IN JUST A LITTLE MORE
THAN A YEAR AND A HALF.
SO THIS YEAR, WHAT WILL YOU
DO IN SALES?
THIS YEAR WE WILL DO
$5 MILLION IN SALES.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE ALREADY
AT A MILLION.
WOW!
THAT'S PRETTY AMAZING.
Kevin: BY THE WAY, OTHERS HAVE
TRIED TO DO THIS
IN THIS SPACE AND FAILED
MISERABLY,
SO I WANT TO HEAR HOW YOU GOT
DISTRIBUTION.
SO, AT TOYS "R" US,
WE'LL BE IN ALL 596 STORES
TO START.
RADIO SHACK,
WE'LL BE IN 1,500 STORES.
WE HAVE DEALS WITH
BARNES & NOBLE,
MICHAELS, NORDSTROM.
WE'RE ALSO EXPANDING
TO CANADA THIS YEAR.
BUT LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE BREAKDOWN
OF SALES PER STORE.
WHAT IS YOUR TURNAROUND?
HOW MANY DO YOU SELL?
SO WE'LL BE IN THOSE STORES
STARTING IN THE FALL.
Mark: YEAH, YOU MENTIONED THESE
ARE ALL ORDERS THAT ARE COMING.
IN THE FALL.
SO YOU HAVEN'T GONE IN YET.
YOU'VE SOLD $1.7 MILLION.
WHERE ARE YOU MAKING
THOSE SALES?
SO WE'RE IN OTHER
ONLINE CHANNELS.
UM, AMAZON IS A BIG ONE
FOR US.
BASICALLY, LAST YEAR WE WERE
PRIMARILY ONLINE,
AND LAST YEAR WE DID
$540,000 IN SALES.
ARE YOU GETTING ANY SALES
FOR BOYS, THOUGH?
'CAUSE IT DOESN'T --
Both: YES.
WE DO HAVE BOYS
PLAYING WITH IT, TOO.
IS IT GENDER-SPECIFIC?
ON YOUR OPENING COMMENTS,
I THOUGHT IT WAS
A PRODUCT TARGETED
TO DEVELOPING YOUNG GIRLS.
YES. WE'VE MADE IT
GENDER-SPECIFIC
IN THAT YOU CAN START BY
MAKING A DOLLHOUSE.
BUT BOYS HAVE COME TO US
AND BOYS ARE PLAYING WITH IT.
WHAT DOES IT SELL FOR?
SO WE HAVE
MULTIPLE PRODUCTS.
THE ONE THAT YOU HAVE
IN FRONT OF YOU NOW,
THAT'S THE STUDIO.
THAT SELLS FOR $29.99.
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU TO MAKE?
IT COSTS US $8.75 TO MAKE.
WHAT DO YOU SELL IT
TO THE STORE FOR?
SO WITH RETAILERS,
IT RANGES FROM $16.50 TO $24.
I'M LOOKING AT YOUR SALES
THIS YEAR.
LET'S SAY $5 MILLION. THAT MEANS
ABOUT A MILLION DOLLARS
WILL BE TIED UP IN INVENTORY.
YOU MUST HAVE BROUGHT ON SOME
INVESTORS BY THIS POINT...
OF COURSE.
...TO CARRY THAT, RIGHT?
YES. WE'VE TAKEN $850,000
IN INVESTMENT,
SO WE OWN THE REST OF IT.
THE VALUATION WAS AT $6 MILLION.
Kevin: $6 MILLION.
I MEAN, I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU,
YOU'VE DONE SOMETHING
REMARKABLE.
THE TOY INDUSTRY'S
BRUTALLY COMPETITIVE.
I MEAN, EVERYBODY ELSE
HAS FAILED. EVERYBODY.
BUT I WONDER WHAT
THE SELL-THROUGH'S GOING TO BE.
THAT'S GONNA BE THE QUESTION.
YOU REALLY PUT THE WHOLE COMPANY
ON THE LINE THEN, DIDN'T YOU?
BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T
SELL THROUGH, YOU'RE DEAD.
WE'LL BE PAID REGARDLESS,
AND WE ALSO HAVE A CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR BUYERS.
LOOK, CONGRATULATIONS
FOR GETTING
THIS AMOUNT OF DISTRIBUTION.
BUT NOW I HAVE TO BALANCE --
DO I PAY
BECAUSE I'M SO ENAMORED
WITH THE GROWTH POTENTIAL
BEFORE I GO THROUGH ONE
SEASONAL CYCLE?
SO IN THE TOY INDUSTRY,
YOUR WHOLE FUTURE
IS THIS HOLIDAY.
SO IF YOU DON'T SELL THROUGH,
YOU'RE SCREWED.
♪♪♪
SO THE PROBLEM I'M HAVING
WITH YOUR DEAL
IS I'M BEING ASKED TO PAY
FOR SUCCESS
BEFORE I KNOW WITH CERTAINTY
I HAVE IT.
I'M A PRAGMATIC INVESTOR
THAT UNFORTUNATELY KNOWS
EVERYTHING ABOUT TOYS.
EVERYTHING THERE IS TO KNOW.
[ LAUGHS ] AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
ABSOLUTELY EVERYTHING.
WE KNOW YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING ABOUT TOYS.
I KNOW. SO TO BUY
THIS VALUATION NOW,
WHICH IS EXTREME STRETCH
FOR ME --
I'M NOT GONNA DO IT.
I'M OUT.
WELL, I THINK LOOKING AT
HOW MUCH WE'VE GROWN, START--
FOR OUR VERY FIRST YEAR,
WE DID $174,000 IN REVENUE.
LAST YEAR WE DID $540,000.
THIS YEAR WE'RE ON TRACK
FOR $5 MILLION.
IF THEY SELL THROUGH.
IN THE NEXT YEAR, WE'LL ALSO
BE EXPANDING INTERNATIONALLY.
THAT, CONSERVATIVELY,
IS $12 TO $13 MILLION.
HERE'S WHAT BUGS ME
ABOUT THIS.
WHEN YOU FIRST STARTED
YOUR PITCH, I LIT UP.
MM-HMM.
A TOY FOR GIRLS.
AND YET I LOOKED AT
YOUR LITTLE PACKAGE.
THERE'S NOT THE WORD "GIRL"
ON THERE.
JUST A SMILEY GIRL FACE,
BUT IT DOESN'T SAY
ANYTHING ABOUT GIRLS.
I FEEL LIKE YOU WEREN'T LOYAL
TO YOUR ORIGINAL POSITION.
GIRLS SEE THIS PACKAGE.
THEY KNOW IT'S FOR THEM.
BUT YOU DON'T NEED
TO PANDER TO THEM...
BUT WHY NOT --
...AND PUSH IT DOWN THEIR THROAT
THAT IT'S FOR GIRLS.
NO, BUT WHY NOT DRIVE IT HOME
AND TARGET IT RIGHT TO
THAT SWEET SPOT?
YOUR ONLY POINT OF DIFFERENCE,
REALLY, BETWEEN YOUR PRODUCT
AND THE REST OF THE DOZENS
OUT THERE
IS THAT THIS IS
FOR THE LITTLE GIRL.
AND SOMEHOW YOU DIDN'T
COMMUNICATE THAT WELL,
AND SO IT FELT
DISAPPOINTING TO ME.
AND SO FOR THAT REASON
I'M OUT.
Mark: GUYS, UM,
YOU KNOW,
GROWING UP IN PITTSBURGH,
MY DAD DID UPHOLSTERY ON CARS.
IF YOU WOULD HAVE TOLD ME
I'D HAVE THIS NET WORTH,
I WOULD HAVE LAUGHED AT YOU.
MM-HMM.
NOW I HAVE KIDS,
INCLUDING TWO DAUGHTERS --
MM-HMM.
7 AND 10.
AND NOW MY BIGGEST FEAR
IN LIFE
AFTER MY KIDS' HEALTH
IS THAT THEY DON'T TURN OUT
TO BE JERKS.
[ LAUGHS ]
RIGHT? THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
A SENSE OF ENTITLEMENT.
SO I'M GONNA MAKE YOU AN OFFER,
BUT IT'S GOT CONTINGENCIES.
Both: OKAY.
OKAY?
I'M GONNA OFFER YOU
$500,000...
OKAY.
...FOR 5%.
RIGHT?
BUT THE CONTINGENCIES ARE
THAT MY DAUGHTERS
ALYSSA AND ALEXIS
CAN COME OUT AND SPEND TIME
WITH YOU GUYS, BE PART OF IT.
YOU KNOW, I TRY TO PUT THEM
IN A POSITION
WHERE THEY HAVE
GOOD ROLE MODELS.
BECAUSE OF ALL THE THINGS
IN LIFE I CAN BUY,
THAT'S SOMETHING
I CAN'T BUY.
AND THAT'S WHAT I WANT
TO BE PART OF.
SO I'M INVESTING IN YOU.
YOU GUYS ARE GREAT.
I BELIEVE IN THE BUSINESS.
BUT I THINK MARK MADE YOU
EXACTLY THE OFFER
THAT YOU ASKED FOR.
SO...I'M OUT.
Lori: YOU KNOW,
INSTEAD OF KICKSTARTER,
MY FEMALE ENTREPRENEURS,
SOMETIMES THEY CALL ME
THE "CHICKSTARTER"...
[ LAUGHTER ]
BECAUSE I'VE STARTED SO MANY
FEMALE-BASED BUSINESSES.
Alice: THAT'S GREAT.
SO I THINK IT'S SO IMPORTANT
THAT YOUNG WOMEN TODAY,
THAT THEY THINK THEY CAN DO
AND BE ANYTHING.
SO I'D BE HAPPY TO GO IN ON IT
WITH MARK.
$500,000 FOR 5% EQUITY STAKE,
IF MARK IS WILLING
TO GO IN ON IT.
YOU'D GET TWO BIG SHARKS,
ONE IN THE TECH SPACE,
ONE IN THE INVENTOR SPACE,
AND WE'LL HAVE THIS ON QVC
WITHIN FOUR MONTHS.
YES. YOU HAVE A DEAL.
GREAT.
DONE.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NO, THEY'LL LOVE IT.
THEY'LL LOVE IT.
AND SMART -- GOOD GIRLS.
Alice and Bettina: THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANKS.
Robert: THANK YOU.
Both: [ LAUGHING ]
WE'RE IN SHOCK.
WE FEEL AMAZING RIGHT NOW.
I MEAN, WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING WITH MARK AND LORI.
IT COULDN'T GET BETTER
THAN THAT. WE'RE SO EXCITED.
MARK DID IT 'CAUSE HE'S TOO RICH
AND TOO NUTS
AND TOO MUCH IN LOVE
WITH HIS KIDS.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH BUSINESS.
AND PLUS WE CAN MAKE THEM
SUCCESSFUL.
I DON'T GET IT.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT.
OKAY, GUYS,
A MOMENT OF SILENCE
FOR THAT MONEY THAT JUST DIED.
ABSOLUTELY.
I'M WITH YOU THIS TIME.
[ LAUGHS ] OH, MY GOD.
Robert: OHH.
IN SEASON FOUR, 18-YEAR-OLD
LANI LAZZARI
MADE A DEAL WITH MARK CUBAN
FOR HER ALL-NATURAL SKIN CARE
COMPANY SIMPLE SUGARS.
I WOULD LOVE TO ACCEPT
YOUR OFFER.
THAT'S WHAT I LIKE TO HEAR.
LET'S SEE WHAT SHE'S UP TO NOW.
SINCE MAKING A DEAL
ON "SHARK TANK"
A YEAR AND A HALF AGO,
BUSINESS HAS BEEN
ABSOLUTELY FANTASTIC.
I'M HERE TODAY
IN NEW YORK CITY
BECAUSE I'VE JUST SIGNED
A MAJOR DEAL
WITH DESTINATION MATERNITY,
THE LARGEST MATERNITY
RETAILER IN THE WORLD.
THEY HAVE DECIDED TO CARRY
SIMPLE SUGARS
IN ALL 575 LOCATIONS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
I'M VERY EXCITED TO BE HERE
WITH YOU GUYS TODAY.
I'VE BEEN INVITED
TO TRAIN THEIR SALES TEAM
AND OFFICIALLY LAUNCH
SIMPLE SUGARS IN THEIR STORES.
YOU WANT TO SCRUB AROUND
UNTIL YOU FEEL
THE SUGAR START TO MELT.
AT OUR LAST UPDATE,
WE HAD JUST REACHED
A MILLION DOLLARS IN SALES.
NOW, ONLY A YEAR LATER, WE'VE
REACHED $3 MILLION IN SALES,
AND OVER THE NEXT 12 MONTHS
WE'RE EXPECTING
TO DO AN ADDITIONAL $4 MILLION.
HEY, LANI.
HEY, MARK.
SHOWING MARK THAT HE MADE
THE RIGHT INVESTMENT
IS SOMETHING THAT DRIVES ME
EVERY DAY.
I HAVE A CHECK
FOR $200,000.
[ LAUGHS ]
THE AMERICAN DREAM
IS ALIVE AND WELL!
Mark: I INVESTED IN LANI
BECAUSE I WANT TO SEE
THAT $100,000 TURN INTO
$20 MILLION.
AND THE BEST PART IS, THERE'S
A SHOT THAT THAT CAN HAPPEN.
SHE'S THAT GOOD.
THIS IS THE NEW PACKAGING.
Lani: THE "SHARK TANK"
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN
ONE OF THE BEST THINGS
THAT'S EVER HAPPENED TO ME.
"SHARK TANK" HAS GIVEN ME
AN OPPORTUNITY
THAT MOST PEOPLE WILL NEVER GET,
AND I WILL FOREVER BE
GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
♪♪♪
MY NAME IS TIGGS CHIRIGA,
AND I LIVE IN MOORESVILLE,
NORTH CAROLINA,
WITH MY WIFE DIANA
AND MY 4-YEAR-OLD DAUGHTER,
AND I GOT ANOTHER BABY
ON THE WAY.
GO! GO!
I CAME TO THE STATES, UH,
ALL THE WAY FROM ZIMBABWE
14 YEARS AGO.
I EARNED
A BASKETBALL SCHOLARSHIP,
AND I FACED A LOT
OF CHALLENGES,
BUT ULTIMATELY I WORKED MY WAY
TO AN M.B.A.
RIGHT NOW, I'M A CLERK
AT A POST OFFICE,
BUT I REALIZE THERE'S SOMETHING
GREATER OUT THERE FOR ME,
AND THAT'S WHY I'M FOLLOWING
MY DREAM
AND STARTING MY BUSINESS.
I DID A FANTASTIC JOB
LAUNCHING MY PRODUCT,
BUT NOW THAT EVERYBODY'S
INTERESTED,
I DON'T HAVE THE CAPITAL
OR THE INVENTORY
TO MEET THE DEMAND.
[ SPEAKING INDISTINCTLY ]
THE SUCCESS OF MY PRODUCT
MEANS A BETTER FUTURE MY FAMILY,
AND I KNOW
A DEAL WITH THE SHARKS
CAN MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
[ GIGGLES ]
♪♪♪
HELLO, SHARKS!
MY NAME IS TIGGS.
I LIVE IN MOORESVILLE,
NORTH CAROLINA,
AND I'M THE FOUNDER OF
THE FLOATING MUG COMPANY.
I'M SEEKING $75,000
IN EXCHANGE
FOR 15% OWNERSHIP
IN MY BUSINESS.
THIS IS QUITE SIMPLY
THE SEXIEST MUG YOU'LL EVER
LAY YOUR EYES ON.
OF COURSE, KEVIN, YOUR MUG
IS A CLOSE SECOND.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'M NOT A PROFESSIONAL DESIGNER,
BUT I HAD A SCREECHING PROBLEM,
AND I NEEDED A SOLUTION.
YOU SEE, MY WIFE MAKES
A VERY PARTICULAR SOUND,
AND IF YOU'LL LET ME,
I'M GONNA TRY AND REPRODUCE
THAT SOUND FOR YOU.
IT GOES SOMETHING LIKE THIS...
[ High-pitched ] "TIGGS!"
[ LAUGHTER ]
NOW I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
THINKING, BUT YOU'RE WRONG.
THAT'S NOT A MATING CALL.
THAT'S THE SOUND MY WIFE MAKES
EVERY TIME SHE DISCOVERS
A COFFEE STAIN
ON OUR FURNITURE.
WHEN I'M DISTRACTED, I DON'T
HAVE THE MENTAL CAPACITY
TO SEARCH FOR A COASTER
JUST TO PUT MY CUP DOWN.
SO THE INEVITABLE HAPPENS --
A COFFEE STAIN MAGICALLY
APPEARS UNDER MY CUP.
AND WITHIN MINUTES --
[ High-pitched ] "TIGGS!"
[ LAUGHTER ]
I KNEW AT THAT MOMENT
I WAS A DEAD MAN WALKING.
BUT THERE'S GOOD NEWS.
I NO LONGER HAVE TO LISTEN
TO THAT DEATHLY SOUND.
THE FLOATING MUG
IS THE ULTIMATE MARRIAGE
BETWEEN A MUG AND A COASTER,
AND TOGETHER,
IT'S THE PERFECT
ELEGANT SOLUTION.
I BROUGHT SOME SAMPLES
FOR YOU GUYS.
I'VE GOT THESE
IN SPECIAL COLORS.
THAT'S ADRENALINE WHITE.
Robert: OOH.
THIS IS HERO WHITE.
THAT'S A PERPETUAL WHITE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU'RE MY MAN, TIGGS.
THAT'S AWESOME.
THAT'S THE FINAL WHITE,
AND THIS IS HOME TEAM WHITE.
THERE YOU GO.
Kevin: [ LAUGHS ]
DOES THE BOTTOM BREAK OFF
A LOT?
HOW DOES THIS HOLD UP
OVER TIME?
WELL, THIS IS A VERY
WELL-MADE PRODUCT.
IS THERE A PIECE OF METAL
IN HERE?
NO. THIS IS
ALL PORCELAIN.
THE WHOLE THING?
WHOLE THING IS PORCELAIN.
HOW ARE YOU SELLING THEM NOW,
AND WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
UM, SO IF I GIVE YOU
SOME CONTEXT,
I STARTED --
I LAUNCHED THIS ON --
IT'S NEVER GOOD
WHEN IT'S NOT A NUMBER.
RIGHT. YEAH.
OUR FIRST YEAR SALES
WAS $105,000.
THAT'S NOT BAD.
THAT'S GREAT!
YEAH, THAT'S NOT BAD AT ALL.
WHO DID YOU SELL THEM TO?
OUR BIGGEST CUSTOMER WAS
A DISTRIBUTOR
THAT WE GOT IN TOUCH WITH.
SO GIVE US THE NUMBERS, TIGGS.
WHAT DOES IT COST TO MAKE IT?
WHAT DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
WHERE DO YOU SELL IT?
ALL RIGHT, SO --
AND WHERE DO YOU MANUFACTURE IT?
ORIGINALLY, WE STARTED
MANUFACTURING
IN THE CZECH REPUBLIC,
BUT IT COST ME
$12 TO LAND THIS
FROM THE CZECH REPUBLIC.
INDIVIDUALLY?
INDIVIDUAL MUGS.
SO WHAT DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
SO RIGHT NOW WE'VE BEEN
SELLING IT FOR $29.99.
WE DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT PRICE.
[ EXHALES ]
BUT WE FOUND A REALLY GREAT
ITALIAN-BASED MANUFACTURER
WHO'S WORKING WITH US TO NOW
START PRODUCING THIS IN CHINA.
SO WE'VE GONE FROM
A $12 LANDED
TO NOW WE'RE AT $4 LANDED.
TIGGS, I ACTUALLY USED TO BE
IN THE GLASS BUSINESS
WAY, WAY, WAY BACK WHEN.
WHAT WE LEARNED ABOUT
THAT BUSINESS
WAS YOU HAVE TO BUY
IN MASSIVE QUANTITY
BECAUSE OF THE PRICE POINTS.
FOR IT TO GET DOWN TO $4,
WHAT QUANTITY
DO YOU NEED TO BUY?
SO OUR ORDER QUANTITY'S
19,500 UNITS.
WOW.
WHAT WAS THE RETAIL
PRICE GONNA BE?
$19.99.
HERE'S WHAT I'M WORRIED ABOUT.
Robert: [ SPEAKS INDISTINCTLY ]
LET ME EXPLAIN ONE THING,
THOUGH.
MY OPTION IS,
WHEN I GO TO STORE,
I CAN BUY A PORCELAIN MUG
OF RELATIVELY SIMILAR QUALITY
FROM SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
6 AND 9 BUCKS.
NOW, I CAN ALSO GET A COASTER
FOR ABOUT 80 CENTS.
SO WOULD THE AVERAGE CONSUMER
PAY 100% PREMIUM
FOR THE FLOATING MUG?
AND I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER
TO THAT,
AND CERTAINLY YOU HAVEN'T
PROVEN IT IN THE MARKET YET.
SO MY -- MY RESPONSE
TO THAT, KEVIN, UM --
YOU CAN SAY THAT FOR ANYTHING.
AT WHAT POINT DOES
A $10 PAIR OF SUNGLASSES
BECOME A $200 PAIR
OF SUNGLASSES?
WHEN IT'S REALLY,
REALLY SPECIAL.
IS THIS SPECIAL ENOUGH?
THIS IS JUST A PRODUCT.
WHAT I WANT YOU
TO FOCUS ON IS THE CONCEPT.
THIS IS OUR PROOF OF CONCEPT
FOR BEVERAGE PRODUCTS
THAT HAVE INTEGRATED
COASTER FUNCTIONALITY.
LIKE?
WELL, I WOULD LIKE TO SHOW YOU
A PROTOTYPE I'M WORKING ON.
SO JUST TO GIVE YOU
AN IDEA,
THAT'S A DRINKING GLASS.
AND WHAT'S THE BENEFIT?
IT'S A BUILT-IN COASTER.
SO AS IT SWEATS,
EVERYTHING GETS CAUGHT
IN THAT RESERVOIR,
AND IT'S GOT A WALL,
SO AS YOU DRINK, IT'S NOT
GONNA SPILL ON YOU.
Robert:
DO YOU HAVE A PATENT ON IT?
ON THE GLASS IT'S PENDING.
ON THIS IT'S ISSUED.
Kevin: WHEN MARKETS CLOSE
AT 4:00 IN NEW YORK,
I ALWAYS HAVE
A VODKA AND LEMONADE
WITH LOTS OF ICE
IN A TALL GLASS.
THE PROBLEM WITH IT IS
IT SWEATS LIKE CRAZY,
'CAUSE IT HAS A LOT OF ICE.
CAUSES CONDENSATION ON MY DESK.
RIGHT. RIGHT.
NOW, THAT'S A PROBLEM.
I WOULD BE WILLING
TO PAY A PREMIUM
TO SOLVE THAT PROBLEM,
KNOWING I HAVE TO FACE IT
WITH CERTAINTY EVERY DAY.
KEVIN, WHILE THIS
MIGHT BE A NICHE PRODUCT,
THIS GIVES ME CREDIBILITY.
IT SHOWS YOU THAT I CAN
DELIVER A WORLD-CLASS PRODUCT.
TIGGS, THE DOWNSIDE IS
YOU'RE ALWAYS GONNA BE COMPETING
WITH A STANDARD MUG
AND A 50-, 80-CENT COASTER.
IT'S NOT A TASK I WANT TO TRY
AND DO,
'CAUSE I DON'T THINK I'M GONNA
MAKE ANY MONEY DOING IT.
OH, KEVIN,
BEFORE YOU KEEP TALKING --
HA!
THERE'S NOTHING YOU CAN DO
TO STOP ME.
I HAVE TO MAKE DECISIONS
AS AN INVESTOR
EVERY DAY IN THE SHARK TANK.
OKAY.
I LOOK FOR THE PATH
OF LEAST RESISTANCE
FOR THE HIGHEST RETURNS,
'CAUSE I'M THE ONLY
DISCIPLINED INVESTOR HERE.
MAYBE YOU CAN GET AN EMOTIONAL
CONNECTION GOING WITH BARBARA,
WHO LOVES TO SPEND MONEY
WHEN SHE STARTS TO CRY.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S
GONNA HAPPEN,
BUT FOR ME, THIS ISN'T
GONNA WORK.
I'M OUT.
SO, HERE'S MY CONCERN
WITH THIS.
I THINK THE MARKET FOR PEOPLE
THAT ARE GONNA PAY
A PREMIUM FOR SOMETHING THAT
DOESN'T LEAVE A COFFEE STAIN
IS ME, KEVIN MAYBE,
AND A COUPLE OTHER PEOPLE.
BUT I DON'T SEE IT
AS A WIDE ACCEPTABLE PRODUCT
THAT'LL DRIVE
YOUR PRICE POINTS DOWN.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
TIGGS!
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU OBVIOUSLY HAVE
A HIGH MOTOR.
YEAH.
AND YOU GRIND.
MY CHALLENGE IS THAT
THE HIGH MOTOR APPROACH TO THIS
WOULD HAVE BEEN ON THE WEB.
POUNDING IT THROUGH
A WEB SITE,
AND SELLING A THOUSAND
MAKES YOU $17,000.
SELLING 5,000 MAKES YOU
$85,000.
IN MY MIND,
THE STRATEGY WAS WRONG.
YOU SHOULD HAVE TAKEN
THE HIGH MOTOR APPROACH
WITH THE WEB, 'CAUSE YOU CAN
CONTROL YOUR OWN DESTINY THERE.
AND BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T,
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
OKAY.
BARBARA, I NEED YOU HERE.
YOU KNOW, I THINK THIS ITEM
IS A ONE-TIME PURCHASE,
AND I THINK IT'S A GIFT ITEM.
I DON'T ENVISION SOMEONE
BUYING A SET OF SIX.
OKAY.
I HOPE I'M WRONG,
'CAUSE I REALLY LIKE YOU.
[ LAUGHS ]
SADLY, I'M OUT.
OKAY.
ONE SHARKETTE LEFT.
Lori: SO, FOR ME,
LOOKING AT THIS,
I THINK IT SHOULD BE
A LOWER PRICE POINT,
BECAUSE I THINK IT MAKES
YOUR JOB EASIER
IF MORE PEOPLE CAN AFFORD IT.
TO ME, HIGH END FOR THIS
IS LIKE $8.99,
$9.99 MAX.
THIS IS THE ONE
THAT I THINK IS REALLY CLEVER.
I DON'T LIKE THE SILICONE BAND.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT IF YOU
COULD TAKE THIS
AND HAVE IT ALL ONE
INTEGRATED BLOWN PIECE
SO THAT YOUR CATCH HERE
IS MADE OUT OF GLASS,
ALL INTEGRATED AS ONE
SO IT'LL STILL LOOK
SLEEK AND BEAUTIFUL,
TO ME, THIS IS YOUR HERO.
THIS IS THE MONEY.
I THINK BECAUSE YOU HAVE
A LOT OF STUDYING TO DO
IN FIGURING THIS OUT,
YOU'RE NOT READY YET.
SO...I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT.
GOOD LUCK, TIGGS.
[ SIGHS ]
I JUST WANT TO DO BETTER,
YOU KNOW?
YOU GET AN OPPORTUNITY
LIKE THAT,
AND YOU DON'T CAPITALIZE ON IT,
IT HURTS.
UH, BUT IT'S JUST GONNA MOTIVATE
ME TO DO BETTER.
♪♪♪
NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS AN INNOVATIVE WAY
TO TIE THE KNOT.
♪♪♪
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS JAMES CASS.
AND MY NAME
IS ADRIAN GONZALEZ.
WE ARE FROM LAS VEGAS,
NEVADA,
AND OUR COMPANY IS
THE WEDDING WAGON.
WE ARE SEEKING AN INVESTMENT
OF $125,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 20% EQUITY
IN OUR COMPANY.
THE WEDDING WAGON
IS THE WORLD'S FIRST
CASUAL AND AFFORDABLE
MOBILE WEDDING SERVICE.
RIGHT NOW, COUPLES
THAT WANT TO GET MARRIED
REALLY ONLY HAVE
A COUPLE OF OPTIONS --
EITHER A BORING CEREMONY DOWN
AT THE JUSTICE OF THE PEACE,
OR A BIG, COMPLICATED,
AND COSTLY WEDDING
AT A CHURCH OR A HOTEL.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE COME IN.
AT THE WEDDING WAGON,
INSTEAD OF THEM GOING
TO THE CHAPEL,
THE CHAPEL COMES TO THEM.
[ LAUGHS ]
AND THE COUPLE CALLS US,
AND WE MEET THEM
AT THE LOCATION OF THEIR CHOICE
THAT MEANS THE MOST TO THEM.
WE BRING AN OFFICIANT
AND A PHOTOGRAPHER
FOR A FUN AND MEMORABLE
CEREMONY.
SO LET'S SAY, FOR INSTANCE,
MR. WONDERFUL,
YOU WANTED TO RENEW YOUR VOWS
OF SHARK LOVE --
[ LAUGHTER ]
WITH BARBARA.
Mark: AW!
EW!
IT WOULD BE SIMPLE.
LET'S DO THAT
IN THE PARKING LOT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AGAIN?
YOU'D PICK UP THE PHONE,
YOU'D CALL US,
AND WE WOULD MEET YOU
AT A LOCATION OF YOUR CHOICE.
AND WE CAN'T THINK OF
A BETTER ONE BUT SHARK TANK.
Barbara: OH!
LET'S SHOW YOU HOW IT WORKS.
I'LL LET YOU KNOW HOW HE KISSES
AT THE END.
[ LAUGHTER ]
HELLO!
THAT'S HYSTERICAL!
Robert: OH, THAT IS HILARIOUS!
BARBARA AND MR. WONDERFUL,
WOULD YOU PLEASE JOIN US?
BARBARA.
YEAH.
BARBARA, PLEASE.
WELCOME, WELCOME, LOVEBIRDS.
I'D LIKE YOU TO TURN
TO FACE EACH OTHER
JUST A LITTLE BIT,
IF YOU WOULD.
James: BARBARA, NO CEREMONY
WOULD BE COMPLETE
WITHOUT FLOWERS.
Barbara: THANK YOU.
[ "BRIDAL CHORUS" PLAYING ]
AND WE'LL PUT A NICE
LITTLE VEIL ON YOU.
HOW DOES THAT SOUND?
Adrian: HERE WE GO.
KEVIN, I'LL BE YOUR RING BEARER
AND YOUR BEST MAN.
OKAY. I ALSO NEED A LAWYER
FOR A PRENUP RIGHT NOW.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WELL, WE ARE GATHERED HERE TODAY
TO WITNESS AND TO CELEBRATE
THE RENEWAL...
I OBJECT!
...OF SHARED LOVE
BETWEEN MR. WONDERFUL
AND THE REAL DEAL.
NOW HOLD HER HAND GENTLY
JUST LIKE THAT.
NOW LOOK INTO HER EYES LOVINGLY
AND REPEAT AFTER ME --
Lori: [ GIGGLES ]
"I PROMISE TO ALWAYS BE
A NICE SHARK..."
I PROMISE TO ALWAYS BE
A NICE SHARK.
"AND TO NEVER INTERRUPT YOU
WHEN YOU'RE SPEAKING."
THAT'S NEVER GONNA HAPPEN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
PLEASE REPEAT AFTER ME --
"I PROMISE TO ALWAYS BE
A NICE SHARK..."
I ALWAYS PROMISE TO BE
A NICE SHARK.
"AND TO UPHOLD ALL OF OUR
DEALS FOR ALL TIME."
AND NEVER DO A DEAL WITH YOU
EVER AGAIN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THAT'S GOOD ENOUGH.
I WILL CRUSH YOU LIKE
THE COCKROACH YOU ARE.
AHH!
[ LAUGHTER ]
I NOW PRONOUNCE YOUR
SHARK LOVE RENEWED,
AND YOU MAY SEAL YOUR COMMITMENT
WITH A KISS.
Mark and Robert: DO IT!
LAST TIME I DID THIS,
I TURNED TO STONE.
HA!
[ LAUGHS ]
YAY!
Mark: OOH!
Robert and Lori: AWW!
VERY SWEET! NICELY DONE.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR BEING
SUCH GREAT SPORTS.
JUST A MOMENT.
HE NEEDS A COVER HERE.
[ "WEDDING MARCH" PLAYING ]
IT'S FANTASTIC.
[ LAUGHTER ]
ALL RIGHT.
THAT IS ADORABLE!
OH!
SHARKS,
WE LAUNCHED OUR BUSINESS
IN THE WEDDING CAPITAL
OF THE WORLD,
AND YOU PROBABLY CAN
FIGURE OUT WHERE THAT'S AT.
[ Singsongy ] LAS VEGAS!
James: ♪ VEGAS ♪
AND NOW WE'RE READY TO TAKE
OUR CONCEPT NATIONWIDE. SO...
Both: WHO'S READY TO SAY "I DO"
TO THE WEDDING WAGON?
WOW!
WHAT DOES IT COST TO GET MARRIED
IN YOUR WAGON?
YOU KNOW, WE STARTED OUR
BUSINESS -- LAUNCHED AT $99.
AND HOW MANY CAN YOU BANG OUT
IN A DAY?
WE DO ABOUT -- WOULD YOU SAY
SIX TO EIGHT, ADRIAN, A DAY?
SIX TO EIGHT A DAY.
WHAT WERE YOUR SALES
LAST YEAR?
$243,000.
WHOA!
WOW!
COME ON.
THAT'S WITH A 2-PERSON
OPERATION.
I GOTTA TELL YOU,
I NEVER WOULD HAVE THOUGHT
YOU WOULD HAVE SAID THAT.
BUT WHAT'S THE EXPANSION PLAN?
IS THIS GONNA WORK
IN OTHER CITIES,
OR IS VEGAS THE ONLY PLACE
YOU CAN DRIVE UP
IN A VAN AND GET MARRIED?
I'M VERY GLAD YOU ASKED
THAT QUESTION,
BECAUSE IT'S A VERY, VERY
EXCITING TIME
IN THE HISTORY
OF THE WEDDING WAGON.
WE ACTUALLY SOLD
THE LAS VEGAS WEDDING WAGON
TO NEW OWNERS LAST YEAR
SO THAT WE COULD DEVOTE
OUR TIME AND ATTENTION
TO LAUNCHING
THE FRANCHISE COMPANY, WHICH
IS WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY.
REALLY?
YES, WE ENVISION
A LOS ANGELES WEDDING WAGON,
A MIAMI WEDDING WAGON.
YOU DID $240,000 IN SALES.
WHAT DID YOU SELL IT FOR?
WE SOLD THE WEDDING WAGON,
THE LAS VEGAS VERSION,
FOR $120,000.
DID YOU SELL THE RIGHTS
TO ALL OF LAS VEGAS
FOR $125,000
FOR THE WEDDING WAGON?
WE DID, YES.
THAT'S IT. SO YOU CAN'T
REESTABLISH...
CORRECT.
A WEDDING WAGON THERE,
AND THAT'S --
Mark: YEAH, BUT IT'S WORSE
THAN THAT, KEVIN.
YOU OWNED THAT, RIGHT?
AND YOU PRETTY MUCH HAD
THE WHOLE GAME TO YOURSELF.
YOU COULDN'T FIND ENOUGH DEMAND
IN THE WEDDING CAPITAL
OF THE WORLD
TO GET TO A SECOND TRUCK?
WE DID ACTUALLY HAVE
A SECOND WAGON.
WE HIRED ANOTHER TEAM.
AND WHAT HAPPENED IS THAT
SUDDENLY OUR TIME
WAS BEING TAKEN WITH,
"SO-AND-SO CALLED OUT SICK,"
AND WE REALIZED
THAT AN EMPLOYEE DOESN'T HAVE
THE SAME COMMITMENT AS AN OWNER.
NO, NO, ADRIAN, COME ON.
YOU CAN'T SAY THAT. YOU CAN'T --
IF THEY WERE MAKING YOU MONEY,
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE
SOLD THAT OFF
FOR HALF OF YOUR SALES.
NOW YOU GOT NOTHIN'.
I'M OUT.
WHAT WERE YOU GONNA CHARGE
FOR A FRANCHISE?
OUR FRANCHISE FEE
IS $25,000.
[ GASPS ]
OHH! NEVER!
ANYBODY CAN GET A VAN
AND THEN DO JUST WHAT
YOU'RE DOING.
TO ME, YOU DON'T HAVE
SOMETHING SALABLE.
I'M OUT.
IT JUST MAKES NO SENSE TO ME.
YOU'VE GOT A VIABLE BUSINESS.
IF I TOOK SOMETHING
FROM ZERO TO $125,000,
I WANT TO RIDE THAT THING
AS LONG AS I CAN.
YOU -- YOU'RE -- IN EFFECT,
YOU'RE GETTING INTO
A NEW BUSINESS...
CORRECT.
...THAT'S UNPROVEN.
I'M OUT.
NORMALLY WHAT HAPPENS IS
SOMEBODY COMES IN WITH
A SUCCESSFUL MODEL --
IN THIS CASE, IN LAS VEGAS.
RIGHT.
THEY THEN TAKE THE FRANCHISEE
POTENTIAL,
BRING THEM TO VEGAS, SAY,
"LOOK. LOOK AT OUR BUSINESS.
LOOK HOW IT'S WORKING.
LOOK AT THE MONEY WE'RE MAKING,"
RIDE AROUND IN THE TRUCK
FOR A DAY, GET A SENSE OF IT.
"BY THE WAY, SIGN HERE
FOR $25,000."
THAT'S HOW YOU DO IT.
YOU'VE DONE SOMETHING
VERY STRANGE.
YOU SOLD YOUR MODEL BUSINESS,
SO NOW YOU ONLY HAVE,
"IT WORKED IN VEGAS.
"LOOK, LOOK, THERE'S
THE TRUCK WE USED TO OWN
BEFORE WE SOLD IT." THAT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE AT ALL.
I THINK I'VE JUST WOKEN
INTO A NIGHTMARE.
TERRIBLE PITCH,
AND I'M MARRIED TO BARBARA.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'M OUT.
WHEN I WAS STANDING UP THERE
MARRYING KEVIN,
I THOUGHT THIS IS --
[ LAUGHTER ]
I WANT MY $99 BACK!
I THOUGHT THAT WAS THE GREATEST
GIMMICK IN THE WORLD.
WHETHER IT BE IN LAS VEGAS,
NEW YORK CITY,
THE IDEA YOU COULD CALL UP
OR JUST GO ONLINE,
BOOK YOUR WEDDING,
MARRY SOME SUCKER, IS GREAT.
Mark: THAT'S RIGHT.
BUT YOU GAVE AWAY
YOUR SHOW-AND-TELL.
IT REALLY IS SUCH A GREAT MODEL.
BREAKS MY HEART YOU SOLD IT OUT.
AND IF YOU STILL HAD
YOUR ORIGINAL ONE,
I WOULD HAVE BEEN IN
WITH BOTH FEET
AND BOTH HANDS CLAPPING.
BUT I'M OUT, SADLY.
THANK YOU, BARBARA.
YEAH.
UNDERSTOOD. UNDERSTOOD.
THANK YOU, GUYS,
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
TAKE CARE NOW.
THANK YOU FOR THE FANTASY.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
YOU GOT IT.
Robert: OR THE NIGHTMARE.
BEING MARRIED TO KEVIN?
THANK YOU FOR THE NIGHTMARE!
[ LAUGHTER ]
I THINK THEY GOT TO CREATE
THE LITIGATION WAGON.
THAT'S RIGHT. YOU KNOW WHAT?
I LIKE THAT BETTER.
I MEAN, YOU SUE SOMEBODY.
YOU JUST OPEN THE DOOR --
"I'M SUING YOU."
[ LAUGHTER ]
IF WE HAD ONE THING
TO DO OVER AGAIN,
BASED ON BARBARA'S COMMENT
ALONE,
IT WOULD PROBABLY BE TO JUMP
INTO A TIME MACHINE...
[ CHUCKLES ] YES.
...GO BACK IN TIME,
AND NOT SELL THE LAS VEGAS
WEDDING WAGON.
EXACTLY.
♪♪♪
NEXT UP ARE ENTREPRENEURS
WHO BELIEVE THEY'VE DESIGNED
A FINER, MORE FUNCTIONAL PIECE
OF SPORTS EQUIPMENT.
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS ERIC WILLIAMS,
CREATIVE DIRECTOR
AT KRONOS GOLF.
AND I'M PHILLIP LAPUZ,
FOUNDER AND DESIGNER
AT KRONOS GOLF.
WE'RE SEEKING $150,000
FOR A 15% STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY.
WE'RE AN INDIE PUTTER COMPANY
THAT MANUFACTURES
THE MOST PRECISE PUTTERS
IN THE WORLD.
YOU MIGHT HAVE HEARD THE PHRASE
"DRIVE FOR SHOW
AND PUTT FOR DOUGH."
PUTTING ACCOUNTS FOR HALF
THE SHOTS OF AN AVERAGE GOLFER.
SO WHY ARE WE BLOWING OUR MONEY
ON DRIVERS
AND SHODDY PUTTERS?
THAT IS WHERE KRONOS
COMES IN.
WE MILL OUR PUTTERS DOWN
TO A 1/1,000th OF AN INCH
TO MAKE SURE OUR PUTTERS
ARE PERFECTLY BALANCED.
WE START OUT WITH
A SOLID BLOCK OF STEEL
AND MILL IT
FOR OVER TWO HOURS,
TRANSFORMING IT FROM STAGE 1,
A SOLID BLOCK OF STEEL,
TO STAGE 2,
A ROUGHLY MILLED PUTTER,
TO STAGE 3,
A MORE REFINED MILLED PUTTER.
IT'S A SLOW,
LABOR-INTENSIVE PROCESS,
BUT IT'S THE RIGHT WAY
TO MAKE A WELL-BALANCED PUTTER.
FROM THERE, EACH ONE
IS INDIVIDUALLY HAND-WORKED,
INCLUDING DELICATE DE-BURNING,
POLISHING, AND PAINTING,
ALL THE WHILE PRESERVING
THAT CRITICAL BALANCE.
THE TRUTH IS, THERE'S
NO PUTTER OUT THERE
THAT'LL MAKE YOU BETTER
OVERNIGHT,
BUT OURS WILL HELP YOU PUTT
MORE CONSISTENTLY,
AND THAT MIGHT BE
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WINNING AND LOSING.
PLUS THEY'RE SUPER SEXY.
SO LET'S GET THE DEVIL
ON THE DANCE FLOOR
AND GIVE THESE PUTTERS
A TRY.
KEVIN, CAN WE ASK YOU
TO COME ON UP HERE?
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GET YOU A BALL.
NOW, ROBERT, NOTE
HOW I'M HOLDING THE CLUB.
SHOULD WE DUCK, KEVIN?
I'M FEELING ONE WITH THE BALL
AT THIS MOMENT.
WATCH THIS GO IN.
WAH, WAH!
Mark: OHH!
Barbara: VERY CLOSE.
A LITTLE SLOW.
PHIL, YOUR PREMISE WAS
AN AWFUL GOLFER LIKE KEVIN
WOULD BE BETTER
WITH YOUR PUTTER.
HERE'S WHAT WE BELIEVE IN.
A LOT OF PEOPLE BELIEVE
THAT THEY CAN BUY THEIR WAY
INTO GOLF
OR ANOTHER SPORT,
WHATEVER IT IS.
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR SOME SORT
OF TECHNOLOGY TO SAVE THEM,
AND THE APPRECIATION
FOR THE PRACTICE
AND THE WORK THAT GOES INTO IT
ENDS UP BEING LOST.
FOR THAT REASON,
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING HERE --
OUR PUTTERS ARE SIMPLISTIC,
AND THEY REFER TO OLDER TIMES.
WOULD YOU AGREE?
THEY'RE FAIRLY SIMPLE?
Lori: YES.
IT ALL COMES DOWN TO
THE MILLING PROCESS.
BUT HOW DO YOU GET
YOUR STORY OUT?
YEAH, HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN THAT?
DEAL WITH
THE DISTRIBUTION PROBLEM.
OKAY, I'LL ANSWER THAT.
I WANT TO BUY A KRONOS,
AND I'M SITTING IN NEW YORK.
RIGHT.
WHERE DO I GO?
ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO WE WENT
TO THE PGA SHOW
AND WE GOT DISTRIBUTION
FOR JAPAN AND SCOTLAND.
BUT NOBODY STATESIDE
WAS INTERESTED?
THEY'RE INTERESTED, BUT THERE'S
THAT ISSUE OF PEOPLE BELIEVE
THAT THEY NEED APPROVAL
FROM A PRO --
IT'S A PROVEN MODEL.
THAT'S HOW PEOPLE SELL
GOLF PRODUCTS.
Lori: WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
THIS YEAR TO DATE,
WE'VE DONE $260,000,
AND WE'VE DONE 95% OF THAT
TO JAPAN.
THEY REALLY UNDERSTAND
THE CRAFTSMANSHIP.
SO WHY IS IT WORKING IN JAPAN?
DO YOU HAVE YOUR OWN DISPLAYS?
NO, IT'S THIS --
NO, IT'S A BRAND.
THERE'S A DIFFERENT PSYCHE
IN JAPAN THAN IN AMERICA.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT AMERICA.
THEY LOOK FOR THAT VALIDATION
IN A PRO PLAYER.
IN JAPAN, THEY HAVE
A LONG HISTORY OF ART,
AND THE DELICACY THAT
GOES INTO CREATING THINGS.
AND ON THAT LEVEL,
THEY APPRECIATE
WHAT WE CREATE
AT FACE VALUE.
THEY TAKE THEIR --
HOW MUCH -- HOW MUCH
DOES IT COST
RELATIVE TO A NORMAL PUTTER?
SO, OUR CHEAPEST PUTTER
SELLS FOR $500.
Lori and Barbara: WOW!
OH, MY GOODNESS.
YOU'RE REALLY A PREMIUM --
CAN I SEE ONE?
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
LET'S DISCUSS THE NAME
FOR A SECOND.
OKAY.
I HAPPEN TO BE AN EXPERT
IN GREEK MYTHOLOGY, OKAY?
[ LAUGHTER ]
EXCELLENT.
THANK YOU. SO YOU KNOW
THAT KRONOS --
HE TOOK A SICKLE
AND HE CASTRATED HIS FATHER
AND THREW THEM
INTO THE OCEAN.
I'M AWARE OF THAT.
NOW, WHAT WOULD THAT HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH A PUTTER?
SO, KRONOS' TIME,
HIS REIGN,
WAS CALLED THE GOLDEN AGE.
WE WANT TO GO BACK
TO THE GOLDEN AGE OF GOLF.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE WEARING
THIS ATTIRE.
Robert: HANG ON A SEC.
EVERYTHING YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT,
ONCE I FEEL IT --
AND LOOK AT THE WEIGHT OF IT.
I MEAN, IT'S --
IT'S A LOT BETTER
THAN ANY OTHER STANDARD PUTTER.
THANK YOU.
BUT WHY COULDN'T YOU GET
DISTRIBUTION HERE IN THE U.S.?
WE COULD ADVERTISE
AND SAY
THAT WE'VE GOT THE GREATEST
PUTTERS, BUT IT DOESN'T --
YOU HAVE TO GIVE A FREE PUTTER
TO EVERY SINGLE PRO SHOP.
THAT'S A HUGE PROBLEM.
Robert: SO CAN YOU -- CAN YOU --
OR AT LEAST TO THE PEOPLE
ON THE PGA.
EXACTLY.
YES, THAT'S NOT A PROBLEM
TO GET A PRO.
IT'S JUST, HOW MUCH DO YOU
WANT TO PAY THEM, RIGHT?
ERIC, $500 IT SELLS FOR
AT RETAIL.
TELL ME WHAT IT COSTS YOU
TO MAKE
AND TELL ME WHAT YOU SELL IT
TO THE STORES AT.
SURE. COST ROUGHLY IS ABOUT
$120 PER CLUB TO MAKE.
BUT WE SELL THEM WHOLESALE
FOR AROUND --
OUR CHEAPEST ONE IS $200
TO $230.
HOW MUCH MONEY HAVE YOU
RAISED SO FAR?
NONE. IT'S REALLY MY MONEY.
I WORKED IN CONSULTING
BEFORE THIS, AND I --
HOW MUCH MONEY DID YOU
PUT INTO IT?
WE HAVE ABOUT $100,000
INTO IT.
Mark: GUYS, LET ME
GET THINGS ROLLING HERE.
I MEAN, HAVE YOU EVER HEARD
OF DALLAS NATIONAL?
NO.
I HAVE NOT.
IT'S ONE OF THE NICEST COURSES
IN THE COUNTRY.
IT OPENED IN DALLAS
PROBABLY TEN YEARS AGO,
AND ONE OF MY FRIENDS --
"YOU GOTTA JOIN,
YOU GOTTA JOIN."
I JOINED TEN YEARS AGO.
I'VE NEVER BEEN.
[ LAUGHS ]
'CAUSE I HATE GOLF.
Eric: PERFECT.
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
OH, MAN.
[ LAUGHS ] BUT I WISH YOU GUYS
THE BEST, AND CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH YOU GUYS.
ONE THING THAT WE TOUCHED ON --
CAN I INTERJECT HERE?
SURE.
YES.
I, AMONG EVERYBODY UP HERE,
SHOULD LOVE THIS SPORT
MORE THAN ANYBODY ELSE,
BECAUSE IT SAVED MY MARRIAGE.
IT GETS RID OF MY HUSBAND
EVERY WEEKEND.
[ LAUGHING ]
BUT I HATE GOLF.
I COULDN'T IMAGINE
SUPPORTING IT.
I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
THANKS.
SO, LAST YEAR, WE DID
SOMETHING IN JAPAN
WHICH HELPED OUR SALES
A LOT.
BUT HOW -- YOU HAVEN'T SOLVED
THE DISTRIBUTION PROBLEM.
FOR THE U.S.
THERE ARE CASES WHERE
SOMETHING CATCHES FIRE
IN GOLF,
AND EVERYBODY BUYS IT.
SURE.
I MEAN, LIGHTNING STRIKES,
AND MAYBE IT COULD STRIKE YOU,
BUT IT'S A LONG SHOT.
♪♪♪
TWO SHARKS ARE OUT.
PHILLIP AND ERIC ONLY HAVE
THREE MORE CHANCES
TO MAKE A DEAL FOR THEIR
HANDCRAFTED PUTTER COMPANY,
KRONOS.
THERE ARE CASES WHERE
SOMETHING CATCHES FIRE IN GOLF,
AND EVERYBODY BUYS IT.
SURE.
BUT IT'S A LONG SHOT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK YOUR MESSAGE IS CLEAR --
QUALITY, OLD TIME,
BEAUTIFUL, ELEGANT.
Phillip: THANK YOU.
IF YOU WANT TO KEEP THAT
UPSCALE CRAFTSMANSHIP,
IF THAT'S WHAT'S IMPORTANT,
THEN YOU HAVE A NICHE MARKET
THAT'S GONNA GO FOR THAT.
I THINK JAPAN
IS THE WAY TO GO,
BECAUSE JAPAN IS TELLING YOU,
"WE LOVE IT."
I'M OUT.
TELL ME A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT YOU GUYS.
WHAT MOTIVATED YOU GUYS TO WANT
TO START YOUR OWN BUSINESS?
I, UH...
[ EXHALES ]
UM...
I'M ENGAGED, UH, TO A --
[ SNIFFLING, CRYING ]
[ Voice breaking ]
I'M ENGAGED TO A --
I'M ENGAGED, AND MY FIANCéE
LIVES IN JAPAN,
AND SHE CAN'T COME OUT HERE
UNLESS I MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
[ SNIFFLES ]
[ BREATHES UNEVENLY ]
I COULD HAVE JUST CONTINUED
MY JOB AS A CONSULTANT,
MAKING FINE MONEY...
BUT THIS IS MY DREAM.
[ CRYING ]
WHY CAN'T SHE COME HERE
UNLESS THIS WORKS?
YEAH, WHY?
BECAUSE...I WANT THIS
TO BE STABLE, AND --
YOU CAN'T AFFORD HER
TO COME HERE.
[ SNIFFLES ]
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE TODAY.
IT COULD WAIT, BUT...
I MEAN, I'M --
OH, "WOE IS ME,"
LIKE, I CAN'T GET MARRIED,
BUT...
IT'S LIKE, DO I HAVE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
MY COMPANY OF MY DREAMS
AND MY FIANCéE?
SHE'S SITTING THERE WAITING.
IT'S BEEN TWO YEAR-- TWO YEARS
SINCE I PROPOSED TO HER.
AND...
AT THAT TIME, I WAS WORKING
IN CONSULTING,
AND HER PARENTS APPROVED.
AND NOW THEY DON'T APPROVE.
THEY THINK I'M CRAZY.
[ SNIFFLING ] AND --
BECAUSE OF THE -- BECAUSE
YOU STARTED A BUSINESS?
YEAH. I -- I THINK
IN THEIR CULTURE,
THEY'RE A LITTLE BIT
MORE CONSERVATIVE
IN THE SENSE THAT THEY VALUE
SOMEONE WHO GOES
NINE-TO-FIVE JOB OR --
SO CULTURALLY IT'S HARD.
THEY DON'T SEE THE VALUE --
YEAH. [ SNIFFLES ]
[ CRYING ]
IT'S MOVING,
I GOT TO TELL YOU.
[ CRYING ]
I THINK YOU OUGHT
TO SIT TONIGHT
AND WRITE HER PARENTS
A THANK-YOU NOTE.
AND YOU OUGHT TO START
LIKE THIS --
"THANK YOU FOR THE INSULTS,
"FOR NOT THINKING I'M WORTHY
ENOUGH FOR YOUR DAUGHTER.
WATCH ME NOW,
AND WATCH WHAT I DO."
THEY'RE NO BETTER MOTIVATION
IN THE WORLD
THAN SOMEBODY WHO INSULTS YOU.
THOSE PARENTS ARE GUARANTEEING
YOUR SUCCESS.
AND IF YOUR FIANCéE
DOESN'T MARRY YOU,
I WILL MARRY YOU.
[ LAUGHTER ]
MOVE TO JAPAN QUICKLY!
PHILLIP, I WILL --
YOUR STORY REALLY MOVED ME,
I GOTTA TELL YOU.
IT'S PAINFUL TO LISTEN
TO THAT.
ASK -- ASK HIM TO PUT
HIS MONEY WHERE HIS MOUTH IS.
THAT'S THE CHALLENGE.
Lori: THAT'S RIGHT.
IF YOU WERE CRYING,
HELP HIM OUT.
I WAS. I WAS MOVED
BY THAT STORY,
BUT NOW I'M BACK IN REALITY.
YOU KNOW...
I'D LOVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DO THIS,
BUT I THINK IT'S --
IT'S A VERY, VERY
DIFFICULT TASK.
YOU DON'T WANT TO LET EMOTIONS
MAKE FINANCIAL DECISIONS,
AND I DON'T, AND THAT'S
WHAT'S KEPT ME TRUE
AS A GREAT INVESTOR.
I'M OUT.
YOU HAVE ONE SHARK LEFT.
PHILLIP, ERIC, YOU HAVE
ONE SHARK LEFT.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
[ CLICKS TONGUE ]
LOOK, I --
IN THE SIX YEARS
WE'VE BEEN UP HERE,
HERE'S WHAT I'VE LEARNED.
PEOPLE THAT SUCCEED IN LIFE
TEND TO HAVE A NEED
FOR SOMETHING GREATER
THAN THEMSELVES.
I HAVE A HUGE CHIP
ON MY SHOULDER.
THE GUYS ALWAYS MAKE FUN
OF ME.
AND IT ALWAYS GOES BACK
TO THE NEED
TO IMPROVE MY PARENTS' LIFE.
YOU HAVE YOUR OWN DRIVE,
AND THAT'S NEVER GONNA GO AWAY.
YOU'RE ALWAYS GONNA WORK
A LITTLE HARDER
AND -- AND KEEP GOING.
BUT IT TAKES TIME.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA CHANGE
THE CONSUMER MARKET LIKE THIS.
THIS IS GONNA TAKE TIME.
THAT'S THE THING
THAT WE HAVE.
THAT'S WHAT I HAVE,
AND I'M WILLING TO PUT IN.
AND I THINK --
YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES YOU MAKE
AN INVESTMENT
BECAUSE YOU SEE
A TIPPING POINT.
MY ONLY POINT TO YOU IS
THERE'S A TIPPING POINT,
AND IT'S FAR AWAY.
IT'S GONNA TAKE TIME
TO RECOUP THIS.
$150,000 FOR 35%.
[ GASPS ] YOWIE.
DO YOU MIND IF WE TAKE
A SECOND TO TALK ABOUT IT?
SURE.
[ SPEAKING JAPANESE ]
SO --
[ CONTINUES IN JAPANESE ]
ARE THEY SPEAKING JAPANESE?
YES.
[ CONTINUES IN JAPANESE ]
[ SPEAKING JAPANESE CONTINUES ]
I-I -- WE'D LIKE
TO COUNTER AT 25%.
I'LL MEET YOU IN THE MIDDLE.
I'LL DO $150,000 FOR 30%.
[ SPEAKING JAPANESE ]
WE --
WE JUST HAVE ONE LAST
QUESTION FOR YOU.
DO YOU WANT YOUR PUTTER NOW
OR LATER WITH YOUR NAME
ENGRAVED ON IT?
'CAUSE WE'D LOVE TO DO
A DEAL WITH YOU.
Barbara: AH, GREAT!
ALL RIGHT!
I'LL -- I'LL TAKE
ALL OF THEM.
THANK YOU. [ LAUGHS ]
GREAT JOB, GUYS.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
CONGRATULATIONS.
I APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YEAH.
I HOPE THE NEXT TIME WE SEE
YOU, YOU'RE MARRIED.
[ LAUGHTER ]
HOW DO YOU SAY "GOOD JOB"
IN JAPANESE?
[ SPEAKS JAPANESE ]
[ REPEATS IN JAPANESE ]
Lori and Eric:
[ REPEATING IN JAPANESE ]
YATTA!
OH, MAN, THAT WAS CRAZY!
Phillip: IT'S GONNA FEEL
SO GOOD
TO FINALLY WIN OVER
THE APPROVAL
OF MY FIANCéE'S PARENTS.
TO KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
A SHARK ON YOUR SIDE
THAT'S ROOTING FOR YOU --
THAT FELT REALLY GOOD.
IT MAKES ME FEEL LIKE I CAN
CONQUER THE WORLD.
[ CHUCKLES ]